good evening everyone
it is my pleasure to invite you all to
the
post talk discussion and conversation
session
in which we heard from professor nishit
vishnui
on friday
as you all may remember professor
vishnoi who is the bartlett gmarty
professor of computer science and
co-founder of the computation and
society initiative at yale university
does uh foundational research on uh
computation and as we saw his expertise
spans from the examples he he gave us in
his talk his expertise spans
multiple uh disciplines and a range of
problems that deal with the issue of um
bias in
algorithms
so today it is a real treat for us to
witness to be able to witness a
conversation between two stalwarts in
the field and our conversant is
professor alexander madri who is the
cadence design systems professor of
computing at the mit electrical
engineering and computer science
department as well as he's a member of
the computer science and artificial
intelligence lab csail at mit he
received his phd from mit in 2011
and prior to getting uh couldn't stray
far from mit prior to that he spent a
year as a postdoctoral researcher at the
mike at microsoft research new england
which incidentally is like stone's throw
away from mit
um but he um he did earn his chops by
going further afar he was on the faculty
at epfl
until early 2015. he currently serves as
the director of the mit center for
deployable machine learning and is the
faculty lead of the csail msr
trustworthy and robust ai collaboration
his research spans machine learning
optimization and algorithmic graph
theory and he has a strong interest in
building on the existing machine
learning techniques to forge a
decision-making toolkit that is reliable
and well understood enough to be safely
and responsibly deployed
in the real world you can see how these
two interlocutors are
going to engage and teach us a lot about
uh some of the challenges that professor
vishnui brought to the fore um
for uh bias in algorithms and how
we are going to since we are going to
encounter them in our daily lives
whether we like it or not
that
for the future
issues of understanding
bias how algorithms reveal our biases
and how in turn not only do they expose
us but
how we can actually learn and mitigate
our own biases
are sort of the kinds of questions that
we are hoping to learn from both of you
so alexander
i invite you uh to take it away and get
started with the discussion welcome
yeah welcome everyone thank you for the
invitation it's really a treat to be
here and treat for many reasons
in particular nishit is someone that you
know is a close friend and you know
there is a lot of parallel between
mine and his trajectory in particular
you know he also was a faculty at epfl
we almost overlapped
i guess we technically overlapped and
you know so that's kind of intensive
institutions but i think more
importantly intellectually there is a
lot of parallels between how we kind of
how our research trajectories evolved
and what kind of questions we were drawn
to so in particular both nishit and i
kind of our roots are in theory of
computer science in optimization
algorithms but again it was interesting
to see that even though we did not
interact that much kind of our interests
in some ways align on the similar topics
so that's kind of you know that says
something
so to be honest after
uh watching uh nishitz talk
i also almost tempted not to have any
slides i thought that he did really
great job of kind of providing a
backdrop for a discussion and kind of
highlighting very important topics but
then since kendall in the talk he
called me out a couple of times that i'm
supposed to say something i will and
hopefully this will provide a little bit
of a different
angle and the questions that you know i
will also articulate towards the end and
so i hope that after this kind of
highlighting i just kind of can have a
very important conversation and one more
thing i want to say is that you know
beyond just me engaging with nishid i
want to view it as a little bit even
on a broader sphere in a sense that i
really think that these questions and
that's what machine you know beautifully
embodies is that like they really go
beyond computing or computer science i
think these are the questions that touch
on all of science and all of our
understanding of society and kind of
different facets of society so kind of a
place like yale
you know kind of is definitely a great
conversation partners for this this kind
of discussion so i guess new [ __ ] can
channel much of this wisdom there but
yeah i'm kind of looking forward to
engage to engaging
so
again let me get started so essentially
as i said you know similarly to nishit
you know until maybe 2016
uh i was happily doing just theory and
that was the only thing i cared about
but then
some interesting things happened so of
course you know we all know that you
know machine learning after some
advances particularly in computer vision
became kind of difficult it became the
thing that kind of you know got
everyone's attention and you know
started to be actually deployed and put
into just about anything
and you know i must say that when i was
observing this kind of as it's things
unfolded i was
somewhat unfazed you know like not the
first kind of not the first hype
happening
not the last one either right so it was
nice to see it was important to explore
but kind of i was not
personally moved
things changed to me though when i kind
of started to ask
myself the question i mean there was
some talk that i was attending you know
just out of curiosity and the question
that kind of i would say is
are we there yet
so in some ways yes we have these
advances you know the things that seem
to be science fiction just like 10 years
ago now we seem to be easy to do you
know like you touch this you the touch
translation it works you touch this it
works so you know are we done did we
find this kind of silver bullet and
essentially all that will happen now for
the next decade or so we will just like
figure out how to polish things how to
scale up things but essentially we are
already there
and kind of that got me thinking about
okay so there are clearly some cool
demos happening there
but what actually would it take
to you know think about machine learning
deployed in a responsible way
okay so well of course you know to even
have a premise of you know a reason to
deploy machine learning in the first
place you need to have performance you
know there has to be some
value that the systems can you know can
deliver and you know i guess this this
was done this was provided that there is
some value in using the systems
but then you especially being a theorist
and thinking of optimization and
different aspects of kind of you know
much of theories about understanding you
know the phenomena at play deeply and
understanding all the ways in which you
know none of this wasted which something
can fail
so you start thinking about like
robustness something about like thinking
about this the question of like
performance on data that is unvetted or
untrusted you think about reliability
about kind of trying to know every
system's failed every system fails but
what is important is that whenever it
fails whenever it kind of moves away
from the conditions of you know that it
was designed to work for it should fail
in a graceful way the question is like
that's what i call reliability like to
what extent this machine learning
systems kind of exhibit this kind of
behavior and then there is also a
additional question of like i call it
interpretability there is many other
ways explainability
and you know and similar but the kind of
the point was that you know there could
be some
desire and need for us to be able to
inspect you know the given model to kind
of provide some quality assurance or
think about regulation regulating the
behavior or essentially trying to you
know provide a bit more of nuance
understanding of what the model is doing
in and and why
and when you start asking about these
facets you realize you know you ask okay
do we have that already and in
particular like much of my work or focus
on the questions for buses and
reliability
the answer becomes quite clearly and
very obviously not at all okay so in
particular much of my work was focused
on this kind of kind of prevalent
brittleness of our current machine
learning tools
so you know one of the most you know
kind of most classical way of
demonstrating this is something called
literally examples so here's an example
of an additional example so we have this
beautiful you know picture of a peak
which state-of-the-art classifier
recognizes the peak with 91 percent
uh confidence so everything exactly is
as advertised but now
the funny thing start to happen if i
start to kind of add a little bit of the
noise to its image this is not a random
noise this is a noise that is created in
a specific way i will not talk about how
but the point this is like very tiny
nose like the image you get after adding
this noise is essentially
indistinguishable to you as a human from
the one on the left so essentially
nothing should change except for this
model suddenly this model is convinced
that what we have here is an airliner
with very high confidence and you might
say okay this is the desired thing you
know this machine learning is able to
make the peaks fly that's kind of
clearly an achievement a bit of strength
but of course this is clearly not you
know what we would intend to happen here
and then it goes deeper you know then it
kind of that this is not just about me
playing with pixels as an image and
getting these results like there was a
bunch of mit undergrads who treated a
turtle that actually like you know
is classified as a rifle from most
angles and
you know and you know and views and also
like you know so previously like this
was more about adversarial
design in which we kind of tried to
engineer for these kind of things to
happen but actually if you look around
at the deployment of you know different
machine learning systems like in tesla's
you see that there is a plenty of
examples where these things just tend to
relatively regularly fail you know like
just here just what happened is this was
in the highway there was an overturned
truck and somehow tesla out of the
autopilot system did not realize that
there is any you know anything in its
way and it just tried to drive through
no one got hurt everything ended up well
but clearly this was a glitch we did not
expect
so now i could spend hours to tell you a
little bit more about different facets
of this brittleness but that's kind of
not
fascinated me and i think also not not
something that would be really that
important for the discussion i think the
question that it's important to ask
ourselves is what is the root of this
bitterness so why is this machine why
why are these machine learning systems
so brittle and essentially long story
short
is that you know one realization that
once you start looking deeply into that
you realize that you know it's about
data in large part it's about like data
matters a lot so in some ways yes you
know we especially when you think about
machine learning kind of we tend to
focus on the models because this is what
draw our attention there is like the new
transformer model
new resnet model
and you know it has that many parameters
and this seems to be the magic but
really you know as much as there is some
magic in that
the you know huge uh you know huge uh
part of you know what drives the
performance of the systems is data
essentially like the data that we
actually make these models ingest and
essentially that end up informing its
decisions so in particular this is
almost obvious to anyone who kind of
thinks about data is that
well essentially if you think about what
our machine learning currently does
all it does really is an excellent
collision extracting so essentially the
way the prediction in quotes is
happening is that well during training
the model kind of figures out different
patterns and data that correlate well
with one label versus the other and then
the way kind of the prediction happens
on the new input is just like you look
at the patterns present in this you know
in this image and you kind of use this
correlation data to pre to make your
prediction and you know on one hand you
know this is a very successful approach
it works you know it does some
remarkable things
but like i actually view it also as a
huge problem
of the current systems and again it
might not be obvious yet but many of the
things that nishi talked about on friday
actually stems from the from from that
so of course the problem is that you
know just curious correlations at the
high level that kind of you know
causation is not correlation we all know
that by now
and you know and the problem is that
okay so that there are correlations that
are not causal but essentially are
spurious
but no the question is like why does it
matter so much and why this is such a
problem
and the problem i would say is you know
twofold first of all if you know that
all of my model is doing is extracting
correlations then well i can essentially
plan this correlations if i'm an
adversary in particular i can plan this
co you know this correlations into my
you know into my data so here let's say
i have docs versus scout training set if
i put you know make the top left pixel
encode the whether this is a docker card
what will happen is the model train on
that will never even bother to learn how
a card or a dog looks like it will just
essentially it would try to read the
color of that pixel that's all if you do
and this kind of you know hijacking of
the decision process of this model it's
actually very important and you know in
particular in the context of security
you know there are some very interesting
and amusing ways of exploiting that so
essentially like this is kind of being a
correlator extractors can be easily
exploited in this way whenever you can
play with data maliciously
but i think the more important point
particularly for today is that this
correlations already exist in our data
right now so just like one example even
in the
data set like imagenet you know it turns
out that you know some of the cut versus
dogs images like you realize there are
like bow ties put on both kind of
animals but it tends to be for some
reason cats more often than dogs and now
that's kind of a funny fact but what
happens after that is that you know
you know what model learns from the such
data is that you know presence of the
bow tie actually is an indication that
you know this image is more likely to
you know to
to be a cat image versus a doc image
right which clearly is not to sound of a
conclusion even if supported by data
and in fact this goes even deeper it's
kind of it turns out that the way we
create data sets gives rise to this kind
of spurious correlations and biases so
my favorite one is just the question
that we might ask so essentially
imagenet is one of the big data sets
that much of research and development of
ml is based on and you can ask yourself
okay so what does a notion of a fish
mean according to image and date
and the important background here is
that immediately source from social
media from a website conflict and you
need to start asking yourself okay if i
never knew like i didn't have a concept
of a fish i've never had seen fish no
one explained to me what the fish is and
i just wanted to learn it from this kind
of data from social media what fish is
well i would be kind of it would be kind
of interesting uh you know interesting
concept of the fish because most of the
like pictures of efficient social media
look like that because you know people
shared social media only because they
want to show the kind of fish they
they saw or maybe the fish they ate it's
there's very few photos of someone
actually diving in and trying to take a
photo of a fish in its natural
environment
but now you know that's kind of natural
to what when you think about it but now
think what happens if you know we kind
of give this data to color to extract
correlation extractor well what will
happen is that the model will learn that
essentially having a human hold
something like that in the picture makes
it into a you know into a fish image
similarly it learns that like the
natural environment for a crab is a
plate because that's where kind of you
know it sees most of the crops so again
so these are kind of some ways in which
these systems learn biases that we would
not think as valid but well they are
supported by data
and of course here we are talking about
just you know
you know
recognizing cats versus dogs or fish you
might say who cares but then these
things do care
do matter when we kind of deploy them in
the real world and essentially in
particular the use of machine learning
in the context of medical context is
right with examples in which kind of
this you know kind of we have predictive
patterns in the quotes that actually are
not what we would like the model to
learn
okay so this is kind of roughly just a
you know a quick kind of run-through of
some of the issues that in particular i
think about a lot and again in a moment
i will connect it to the issues that
nishid thinks about as well because you
know i think what this you know the way
i like to understand what's really going
on here is essentially that there is
this you know what i call human ml
misalignment this kind of this
imaginarization that essentially sucks
us at the task you know the way we
phrase it in a mathematically precise
way
does not mean that the model is doing
what we intended to do that it learns
the concepts the desired concepts that
we want so just in the context of vision
if i want to train my model to recognize
dogs by just saying okay you need to
recognize dog versus cats you need to
get the label right well we have this
expectation that the way the only way to
do it is to learn and to do it the way
the human does to learn that there is
like a different
different kind of
you know fracture of the of the of the
four you know you need to realize how
this like the what the snout is and so
on and that's kind of that's the only
way to you know perform the stats very
well but the reality is that it's not
true that essentially our systems like
ml systems learn very different ways of
solving the tests that completely do not
involve learning any of the concepts we
assume they are learning and kind of so
there's this kind of misalignment with
technology is really using patterns that
we as humans not only would not use but
we might not even able to comprehend
so
so where does it take us and now well it
takes us to first realization that this
kind of if you think about the questions
of you know of essentially all the
questions all the problems that we are
grappling with in the context of
handling including the questions of by
us
they really
boil down to this kind of human animal
misalignment saying we have certain kind
of set of beliefs and then we are have
some mathematical mechanically precise
definitions and we are kind of trying to
like well the worst things happen if we
assume they are the same
in particular
a lot of work that that new shirt is
doing is essentially trying to exactly
like make this mathematically precise
definitions of in particular what
fairness means to kind of meet you know
what you know what is our notion what
will be our desired notion of fairness
so and again we will get back to this in
the in in our discussion but then of
course we have to realize that like you
know the fact that these systems work
differently is also the source of their
performance like they are different to
us that's why they can provide something
that we don't have so there is a little
bit of this tension in particular you
know the way kind of you know i think
the big question here is you know kind
of how do we navigate this trade-off
between kind of lay letting the systems
extract the patterns the way they see
fit which again is the you know that
might lead to also new discoveries
discoveries we actually want to these
models to have versus our you know
instinct actually like responsibility to
make sure we understand what the systems
are doing and that they kind of don't go
out of bounds so the way i kind of like
to put it is that kind of you know we
have a tendency the way these things are
phrased in the popular science that we
think of ml as a hammer you have a
problem you just bring a ml on this and
you are done it's really not a hammer if
i have to use analogy i would call it a
sharp knife something that can work very
well if you know what you are doing but
you can hurt yourself badly and in
particular again collision extractors is
what i call this double edged sword of
ml it kind of gives it its power but
also like the problems with in
particular like realizing that you know
you look at the you know hiring data and
realizes that well you know you can get
you know idea that you know if you play
la crosse and your first name is jared
then you are no you are destined to be
good you know employee you know all of
these things exactly stem from this kind
of you know mistaking correlation for
causation and of course on top of the
biases that our models have
so data matters a lot again this is at
the core of the robust and safety
problems but it also drives a lot of
these you know ml-related inequities
and it also leads to very many other of
unintended consequences that i want i
will not go into
so let me conclude by saying that this
kind of what i view as you know where we
are hopefully trying to go this truly
deplorable ml so ml that we can deploy
and we can feel good about the results
of this this will be an again this is
not something that machine learning
researchers or even computer scientists
solve this is a much broader question so
yes there is a role for machine learners
and engineers
but you know they also need to recognize
that these are really complex and messy
tasks and real world data is really not
what they can just nicely model there is
more to it so that's kind of they need
to understand that role
then there is a role for domain
practitioners they really have to
clarify you know how the data that the
systems are supposed to use was
collected and also what are the actual
correct objectives you know that we
should be after too and finally and
again i don't know how interested
initiate will be going that direction
but i find it very very interesting is
you have to realize that you know there
is a role for decision and policy makers
like need to acknowledge
that there are tradeoffs there
that you know that you know we should
decide how we want to navigate them and
again decide the society because
different tradeoffs might play
differently for different stakeholders
and we need to make a decision
so i really like i already talked too
much about things that relate to my work
if you want to learn more you can see it
here
i just want to close it off at saying
that it's really like you know robust
and reliability is really important and
it's an important kind of question but
is it just a part of the bigger question
of this kind of phenomena that we are
seeing right now the data-driven
decision-making percolates just about
every aspect of our lives you know at
first it was things like i got big
trading that most of us didn't care
about but then kind of slowly but surely
it started kind of you know bordering
and and kind of and you know and touch
on really kind of scary things and i
think the two points that i want to
highlight here is that first of all we
do not understand what these
consequences of using data-driven
decision-making in this context have
like we are only discovering it almost
kind of you know by just trying it out
and seeing what happens really not the
best way to do it but that's that's
where we are and also and again i want
to emphasize it
you know
because this is very important is that
like in all the things i talk about in
my work especially in the vision
you know yes it's difficult to get
reliable and robust systems and there
are many reasons for that for
fundamental reasons for that but at
least we agree kind of agree like you
know what robust and reliable systems
needs like we kind of have a gold
standard of human vision and we kind of
can agree if this is a correct behavior
or not
in many of the questions that you know
we pursue in this broader agenda in
particular the ones that nishit touches
on we don't even know like we don't even
agree necessarily what the desired
behavior is you know we can really
disagree about what is fair what is not
fair and you know and many other
concepts that come out in the context of
the systems and you know like and that's
something that we need to recognize up
front
so i really view it as a really
important challenge for you know for us
scientists but also going beyond that in
particular the question is like how we
as scientists can engage with the real
world to provide some okay we should not
be telling people what to do but at
least we should be able to make sure
they understand what's the problem but
anyway i talked enough and you know i
would like to just move to the
discussion
so i have a few questions but i'm happy
to you know do this [ __ ] based on his
talk but i'm happy to also like you know
follow uh priya's read how we go next
thank you so much alexander for this um
wonderful um you know defining
of your vantage point and your point of
view on on these matters before we go uh
right into um the sort of the question i
had a couple of simple questions that
um
that come from a slightly different
direction uh comes from so you know
machine learning and ai have been uh
hugely considered hugely promising for
example in my fields in astronomy and
physics and other disciplines as a as a
way for revealing as you said these
underlying correlations
that may or may not have causation right
and and the challenge is that in physics
at least we have laws that structure our
expectations so we know that certain
quantities are conserved and so on so
forth so i would like you both to also
engage a little bit about uh the domain
the intellectual domain and
discovery space what what these methods
are doing for discovery space and we are
all enthusiastic but are there things we
need to be cautious about what are the
things you would alert us
scientists in other fields who are all
really excited and want to use machine
learning to do you know um x y and z
and then i also um realized that
in the example that you showed us with
imagenet right um
isn't there an issue of uh
incompleteness of data isn't that like a
fundamental inherent limit right so not
all attributes of dogliness or whatever
dogness
are
known right so
hypothetically
would you both i mean i'd like to hear
both of your uh responses to this if
hypothetically we were able to define
the entire space of attributes complex
multi-dimensional space of all the
attributes that define dogliness
then
would the recognition
in your opinion would that be perfect
would that be enough
how important is the incompleteness
other than the you know sort of planting
and biases the examples yeah so
let me start by taking a stab at both of
your questions for you so for the first
question i think this is very important
to take into account the invariances uh
in the data domain
and there is a branch of machine
learning which is the beginning to do
that
so you know even the examples that uh
alexander was showing
images they have in variances in
particular you can rotate an image and
you should you know your
you should your your opinion about the
image should not change
and uh as far as i remember and it's
going to correct me if i'm wrong
but i mean the original machine learning
systems are not even robust to these
kinds of
just simple rotations right uh am i
right
yes so so and i think the issue there
was that
if we know symmetries
of the of the data
we have to then design algorithms
that take into account those symmetries
uh this then leads to problems on
manifolds because when the moment you
have symmetries
you know the mathematics gets complex uh
the traditional the kind of thing that
ariganza was describing straightforward
euclidean space
you're doing optimization in utility in
space
on manifolds optimization gets
complicated because you know you only
know your tangent space at this point
you don't know you don't necessarily
know how you're going to take long steps
and the computational cost starts
increasing but there is there is
something called geometric deep learning
which is coming up
uh the second question um
i can give a more mathematical answer to
that i mean so the question of what does
dogliness mean is
i'm not sure one can ever define that uh
but you know in his
classic beautiful theory on fact
learnability leslie valiant who's a
during award winner and one of the
founders of learning theory
uh he did introduce the notion of
a
distribution from which data comes
so the setting of learning theory is the
following that you have some
unknown distribution
and you're given independent samples
from that distribution
and so you should only be checked i mean
you know you should only be tested
against samples from those distribute
from that distribution
so the assumption and alexander will
talk much more about it the assumption
in many of these uh algorithms is that
which is wrong as you point out it's not
in i mean it's not necessarily
incompleteness it's like you know we
don't know uh what the openness is what
this distribution is and we certainly
don't
certainly don't
yeah we certainly don't believe that we
have iid the independent samples from
the the space of dog meanness and i
think alexander made this point by these
fishes right which is very very
important
um
so i mean but yeah but
there is a theory i mean in this
literature there is a theory which says
that if you are given samples
uh
from the true distribution
then you can quantify
the quality of the algorithm with
respect to samples from the same
distribution
so yeah i guess that's all i have to say
you know um i was curious because the
reason i asked uh with dogliners is
because you know obviously the more sort
of real-world complex issue is you know
what is the ideal candidate right so
when we are making sort of candidate
selections and so on i mean these things
also keep changing with time it's like
you know uh uh i mean as a society and
i'll move this discussion a little bit
to what alexander was saying towards the
end of his talk
that uh as a society you know we might
have grown up with two genders male and
female but today it's
you know
even that's not true it's very
dynamically changing and
so we don't even know what i mean forget
fairness i mean fairness with respect to
what i mean we don't even know what that
what is i mean you
so we can define fairness once you know
what to define fairness with respect to
right i mean if the notion of dog and
cat is evolving over time
then how can we think about designing
algorithms which are fair with respect
to dogs and cats i mean i think that's
even a more fundamental issue at least
when it comes to things like
bias now probably this is not happening
in the physical world where
you know the equations that govern black
holes are changing
uh you know at least the assumption is
that the laws of physics are not
mutating over time right
so there is there is some differences
between these areas
uh and so maybe one extreme is really
the physical world where things are very
nice well-defined or at least you have
some idea of the model
and i would add that you know
you know even if you go back to the
history of physics and how kepler
discovered his laws i mean i'm not an
expert on all this stuff but
looking at data he discovered new laws
so it is entirely possible that by
looking at data you can revise the laws
of physics
and i'm sure you're working on things
like that yeah
yeah um
that it is true that a lot of the laws
were empirically many of the laws were
actually empirically discovered
that is
definitely true and when the data was
not as complex either and now the data
is much more complex
but um
alexander i might invite you to ask uh
ask nishit any specific questions that
you had in mind sure sure i have let me
just compliment what uh what nishit said
so i kind of just to kind of zoom out a
little bit so like i think if you think
about like
how we create knowledge about the world
there are like two again at the very
high level two ways of doing it one of
them is we postulate models like that's
actually much of what physics is there's
a law of physics and we say this is how
the universe uh kind of you know
like you know works and based on that
with the the life like the experiments
like we have predictions of like how
things should work then there's a
data-driven thing when we exactly look
at the observations and we try to
crystallize from this you know what you
know what symmetry is in yours what
patterns we see so clearly machine
learning is in the second camp
and that's why i can imagine and i can
actually share with you some excitement
about doing that there is a lot of kind
of
i would say practical challenges there
which you know already initially
mentioned to is that saying you know the
sample complexity of learning something
reliable from data is quite enormous and
you really need to have some you know
kind of
essentially so the way
this is called the machine learning is a
prior so i mean like this laws of
universe you need to have a prior so you
posted some symmetries so even to get
vision work you needed to have
conventional neural networks so you kind
of you had to postulate this kind of
spatial invariance as a kind of way to
really reduce the space of concepts that
the model explores so
you know similar things need to happen
in this context of different sciences
and yes geometric
deep learning is kind of trying to
provide a framework for that but anyway
now yeah so the question that this is
that can you ever like is one in like
one approach of you know understanding
the world not building out about the
world better than the other and of
course the answer is no
they are really very complementary like
in some ways you know just like i don't
think that ever you will learn what dog
is just from purely from data
you know but i could imagine that you
know there is certain notion of you know
of something data-driven like you know
the texture of the four you can learn
maybe from data but then there are
certain concepts like this like dog has
two legs you know and all four legs
actually you see my concept of a dog is
changing as well
and other aspects that might be kind of
encoded into the model and again there's
a very interesting question of emerging
matching questions
alexander it's not so much if one method
is better than the other the question is
which is more in the scientific domain
it is which is more reliable in terms of
explanatory power and predictive power
right okay
so that's great so well and again the
question is what reliable means like
clearly you know what we are striving to
is to have like you know beautiful
equations you know that's what physics
excel is like beautiful equations that
explain everything you know you can say
you know read it
and put it of course like well you know
you can have a beautiful year that
doesn't predict anything then you don't
don't care you know but of course we
know that sometimes when we really want
to to fit real well like if you look at
standard model like things become a bit
messy saying oh here we have this
constants and so on and you know again
it's amazing it it like predicts so much
but yes so essentially so the
reliability here is you know like i
think in the end the way we as humans
like i don't think we can communicate
via data to each other what things we
just like i think in the end we are
biased towards models and priorities
because that's the only thing that is
kind of compact enough for us to do in
some ways again i don't want to go too
philosophical but like to me the role of
machine learning is to be kind of a bit
of opposite to us like i think one big
power of ml is just being really able to
understand like in fair simple rules
from a lot of data like essentially
being able to cognitively just parcel of
data even if not a very deep way it's
something complementary like i think we
can go very deep but on very kind of
small like you know kind of volume of
data and kind of ml can do a bit the
opposite in some ways that's why i never
really like when people say about
supplanting humans with ml i think it
really should be always about
complementing humans of ml but like
since you know our notion of reliability
is really kind of we like to have a
concise model that predicts like the
data-driven stuff always should be
hardly less reliable especially we would
like to use it to then formulate the
laws
that we actually are uh comfortable with
thank you
okay uh so so let me kind of ask a
little bit of you know
like a few questions to initiate based
on your talk so essentially like in the
end you like in the talk you already
kind of articulate that there is a
little bit you know there are two
components of this data-driven decision
making
systems it's like one of them is data
like what are the kind of biases and
data to be learned but the other is the
objective you know in the end you are
learning the data like essentially the
model is performing optimization to
you know optimize something
right and as we know by now both aspect
matters so what is your thinking about
the relative importance of this and if
you think about like improving you know
you know the way kind of you know the
systems work moving forward like
ultimately like you know which might be
the easier to improve and kind of like
what is your thinking here like like
like what is the hope here in terms of
improvement
so in terms of i think uh impact uh
the
the objective that you optimize in many
of these algorithms
play a much bigger role in my opinion uh
because the moment you write down an
objective so let's take an example of
college admissions and college
admissions is something where probably
everybody has personal experience with
so when we talk about something like
college admissions uh
we
historically have been using things like
sat scores
to
i mean not to what extent did their role
in the decision that's
been changing and that's debatable but
let's pretend for a moment that you know
there are colleges which will just look
at your sat score and decide whether you
get in or or not
now the real question here is
is what the college looking for
in a student for their university what
is the college looking for in the
student at the university
and why is sat score
uh why are we using sad score
and whether it is the right thing to do
now we are realizing that it is not the
right thing to do because it measures
something else compared to what we are
trying to measure the moment we create a
metric
a metric in this setting is a value
judgment
that we value this
and the moment we create a value system
by writing down an objective function
um certain segments of society will
figure out how to
uh take
be good in that value system as opposed
to what the original objective
of the university is
so i think uh to answer your question in
short i think this is really really
important i mean i cannot emphasize more
at universities we talk about
diversity
and there are like every universities
right now on a path to increase
diversity i would go ahead and say here
that most universities don't have any
idea what they're doing
uh and the reason is
uh because they're not clear what and
this leads to this this brings back to
your point i mean we don't know i mean
the second last point you make
we don't know what the implications of
our policy decisions on increasing
diversities and i mean you know uh
so because in the end we will implement
these diversity decisions based on some
objectives again maybe
you know maybe we will have a dean of
diversity uh you know who is
black and what does being black mean
i mean is it okay if somebody was black
but they lived in uh you know completely
uh
privileged life all throughout their
life so i'm not sure to what extent
these discussions are even happening
and so
the objective function from i mean if
it's you know the objective function as
to how to select a candidate for a
position like this is you know it's it's
it's mismatched it's misaligned as you
you called it so i think
it plays i mean i think the data
component is secondary once there is an
agreement that this is what we want to
optimize
right
that's where then comes the issue of
okay do we know everything about the
data that we need to know
right i mean this question is uh
not specific to bias uh i mean this is
in your work this is in priya's work
this is you know um this happens in
every discipline where data driven uh
discovery is happening right do we know
everything about the data that we need
to know
and
what are these systems in which we can
write down the assumptions on data
so for example i mean i talked a little
bit about
um you know
correlations between uh
data so i do not know what the
correlations might be so maybe i just
used a very strong model an adversarial
model saying that because i do not know
what the correlation is let me quantify
it by saying
that okay
you know the adversary can
introduce arbitrary correlations in data
and i have a measure of how many data
points the adversary can touch and based
on that i will now design an algorithm
based on this knowledge this is meta
knowledge so i think we are moving in
this direction uh we are not moving so
much in the direction of trying to
understand what are the objectives
and i think that cannot be something
that uh be done by technical
mathematical people
you know this is where the domain
expertise has to come in
this is where we have to have even
inside a domain
um we have to have discussions which
take into account
various
sectors in society
you know for example let me give a
controversial quote here i mean you know
the nobel prizes got announced recently
i'd like to make this discussion more
interesting i guess so the nobel prizes
got uh announced recently and the chair
of the nobel prize committee if i'm i
mean you have correct me if i'm wrong
comes out and says
that you know
we are not i mean they were criticized
for not having other than a single woman
uh being awarded and they come out and
make some in my opinion outrageous
statements without any
understanding of what the system is that
the system evaluate
uh women and men the same manner you
know what is the system who decides you
know you know if if you are evaluating
scientific content please do not talk
like this is a you know godly evaluation
process this is a hundred percent human
evaluation processes it says hundred
percent human biases
and we all should acknowledge that to
say the least and certain groups
get
evaluated lower in this not because
their work is any worse
it's just because how the evaluation
systems are set up in society so these
are the things which are uh you know
when we evaluate we should understand
what we are evaluating and you know the
data that is coming to us
could it be biased could the data for
one group be biased compared to the
other so i mean
right from the biggest achievements that
we celebrate to the smallest things you
know in in places like africa we see a
huge disparity in just our understanding
of data
uh you know kovit 19 has shown
what uh you know significant disparities
uh in in data so yeah i think
yeah i mean it's a long answer to your
question but i think the higher order
higher order thing is objective and then
uh the lower order which i think is
currently tractable and at least we are
asking the right questions and you and i
are both working in this uh you know
from different uh for different
objectives like different objectives i
mean like reliability responsibility and
bias but the i think the ultimate goal
is trying to understand
what we can use about the data yeah that
isn't one fundamental issue
that we may not all agree even on the
metrics right i mean that there could be
right
but this is this is this is what i refer
to as participatory design of metrics
yeah i mean in the end we have to agree
right i mean uh so
uh
so we have to identify which group it
affects and and then we have to bring
them onto the table and have a
discussion
yeah but ultimately all of this is a
you know we can go closer and closer to
the true thing but we will never reach
the
uh with the true goal i mean
but for the kinds of uh ml systems to
work do you think we need to become a
society that has shared values first i
mean is that a prerequisite
alexander i'll let you take this is
actually like it's actually going to my
next question in some ways so but before
that like like i like the points you
made me [ __ ] i would just one more thing
is exactly like that even like you know
there is an interesting paper that shows
that even if you kind of try to like
let's say making fairness intervention
in context of consumer lending you know
like you want to make sure the certain
groups which are kind of for system
systemic reasons kind of under
underprivileged that they actually like
to do affirmative action to improve
their lending to them which you know if
you look at this we did something good
in the world then what happens that if
you think about the again remember we
are not only predicting things we are
making decisions and students have
consequences and turns out if you look
at the long-term dynamics that comes out
of that well these people some of these
people actually are not it's really hard
for them to pay back their loans again
there are some systemic reasons behind
that why they don't have enough wealth
but you know this is reality so you are
kind of letting these people you know
get a loan they actually are more likely
to not pay it back and that hurts the
credit score even more so in the end by
having you know intervention that was
supposed to do the right thing you
actually heard them even more as a you
know as a
population moving forward and even
individual ones right so again so this
is very important and this is
unfortunately and i guess this is
something that you know both nishite and
islam and there is not enough even a
recognition of importance of the
objectives like it's in the end it's
about how i make my accuracy better not
even thinking of accuracy on what and
what does it represent and the moment
you start peering under this you realize
that you know there is lots of problems
a lot of
assumption here so but like now going
into my next question because exactly
like i think what i'm learning like this
kind of in my work causes me to think a
lot and your questions and discussions
kind of point to this saying
you know there's a little bit of a
double standards here it's like in some
ways we say oh this machine learning
system you know it's unfair it's kind of
you know doing this doing that and what
is the exact objective that it's using
on the other hand we have human decision
making first of all much of what the
machine learning does is just uncover
the kind of the biases and kind of
inequities of human decision making just
like makes it apparent so maybe that's
the uncomfortable truth here that we
don't want to acknowledge the other
thing is saying if you look about you
know
the admissions decisions are made by
human being committee which you know in
the past talk about character and other
things and defeat and like you know
there is no one like
like in some ways you know like we kind
of seem to be okay with that and now we
are saying all these machine learning
things they are so bad we should not be
using them so so kind of i think there's
a little bit of recording here and i
think that's what pre actually talked
about saying that you know yes and maybe
i agree with you that we should have an
honest conversation about objectives in
particular if we talk about nobel prizes
let's go a little bit there is like
why did we kind of assume that you know
uh some committee of people in sweden uh
kind of decides who are they why are we
even giving away the nobel prizes i mean
this is yes
there could be some value in this but
like it seems to be a proxy for like if
you got a nobel prize you are god of
science if you didn't you didn't and you
know in particular if there's marketing
there's marketing associated to it yeah
so sorry the point is that like i'm not
saying you know every every award has a
problem which is fine as long as you
have honest conversation that you know
this is what these things are and we
should not kind of you know and what we
should have like honest like essentially
recognition of that right
yeah i i um i feel compelled to point
out like one of the things that this
spokesperson was completely you know i
think he revealed his ignorance in so
many ways
i mean the basic point is that there is
a fundamental difference in the number
of women who do get nominated in the
first place
let alone whether they are considered or
not and eventually get the price to not
even kind of understand and acknowledge
that that is sort of a systemic
bottleneck
i mean you know i don't know i it's it
was it was quite um
depressing and irritating yeah
but i think alexander you're right i
mean this is how i i think about this
and this is why i mean you know i
realized that this is why this area got
so much importance because in the end it
showed that definitive proof that humans
are biased because you know it's not
like we're receiving these algorithms
from an other civilization we are
constructing these you know we are
collecting the data whatever is the
reason you know it's a definitive proof
that we are biased and i think that's
why you know with things like kathy
o'neill's book that came out i mean you
know it it caught media attention
uh you know for example uh yeah and and
i think uh
it is giving us insight and
the you know it's like it's providing a
lens to to to our own society uh to our
own self
it is but if you look at the coverage of
this it's not that humans are biased
it's algorithm
like we are really protecting ourselves
from kind of letting these implications
sink in and this is interesting and
again even if you think about people who
you know who kind of talk about these
things even they don't make this point
strong enough because maybe this would
be uncomfortable truth and and so on and
again okay i agree this is actual
definite proof like we i mean
you know while i was thinking about this
talk i realized this so i mean i would
be a little bit gentler because it's it
is uh it is an obvious thing in
retrospect but you know it took me also
a few years to just kind of
have this realization that this is yeah
but maybe there are people yeah i mean
yeah i think certainly a very valid
point that
and now that you mention it that people
say algorithms are bad they don't say
that human design algorithms are biased
right yeah as if algorithms are being
shipped to us from you know mit yeah
which is another planet
we are we only good things come from mit
so
essentially like yeah but like in some
ways again like it's almost like a
rockshox test it's like saying you are
designing an algorithm is saying okay so
what should be the objective and then
you run it through the data and only
then you realize oops you know that's
not what i meant or maybe maybe that's
what i meant all the time but now
it's actually you know led late bear to
us so actually like you know yes so
so this is great so that's exactly a
very important realization that again
like hits you a bit hard once you make
it because you realize okay that's you
know it's all anyway
let's go too much into that but let's
try to see a little bit of a maybe
positive spin to all of this so again
clearly using blindly data driven
decision making
is really bad idea i think hopefully we
all got that message but not all got
that message but hopefully we are
getting this message but now let's think
also like what do we think is the
correct or a bit more beneficial and you
know kind of inclusive and kind of like
i'm talking about shared prosperity kind
of beneficial way of using such systems
like so what are the places where we
should be using them how should we using
them do you have any suggestions you
need
it takes me back to priya's point you
know for for us to
we need to as a society first have some
shared values right so i mean we need to
first agree on what are the values that
we are so yeah there are there are
contexts in which you can imagine that
there are shared values let's say if
you're an organization
a university then in such small
universities you can imagine that people
have some shared values
and there i think we have to work
together to figure out uh the right
objectives that we are
optimizing making sure that we
we know everything about the data
and
that we can know
and then design uh policies or
algorithms
uh based on
[Music]
you know such inclusive and and thorough
thinking that's uh i mean i'm talking
more in general in terms of algorithms
in which i include policies and not just
machine learning just to be very uh
clear in this context
uh because you know uh yeah machine
learning uh i mean i should mention that
the kind of machine learning alexander
does is uh
you know the state of the art
and you know he's using some really deep
architectures
to learn things and
the world of fairness and bias
has
you know has not reached that point that
it can start grappling with objects like
this
and the reason is uh
actually fairly simple uh
at this point
because
uh it's mathematical so let me just kind
of explain uh you know and i think this
is important for some people to might
know i mean alexander would probably
explain it better but let me just try
so so when we talk about objective
functions there is some assumption that
when we will now solve this optimization
problem
there is this one point that we are
trying to reach
right
but there is no such thing in many of
these models that alexander
studies have
they have very very complex landscapes
they have many many local optima you
know and
so what shall i do as a you know as a
person who cares about fairness i mean
at different different points on this
landscape
there may be completely different uh
you know properties related to fairness
so from an accuracy or performance point
of view you can select maybe one and
people have
you know people have
i mean
the thing works in some way because you
know all these local
optimal points are good points but from
the point of view of fairness it's not
at all clear how to even do that maybe
what do you think what do you think yeah
but nishit um just to chime in quickly i
mean but these are these multiple optima
maxima whatever in that landscape don't
they represent basically trade-offs
right value trade-offs
you are trading something there is no
one clear-cut solution but that the
solution space
represents in the case of um
sort of these uh more social domain
problems like trade-offs right um yeah
but i mean i think what we are talking
about are some really
at least i view them as very ugly
landscapes where it's it's it's not i
think what uh
we are imagining that there is uh you
know
that there is uh there's multiple
optimum solutions they are related by
some symmetry and so there is some
trade-off i mean this is just totally
i don't think anybody understands this i
mean alexander complicated
yeah yeah so so definitely no one
understands it like again but i i think
i like the point you made earlier that
like you know because you made the
context of data like we don't even know
what you want to accomplish so like you
know figuring out how to then make this
model do what you want to accomplish
that's almost a secondary concern even
though that's not been non-trivial right
like i think
again there's just so much not thinking
about like what we are even trying to do
that like yeah like yes we have problems
with enforcing the behavior we want but
like i wouldn't say this is the root of
the pro like this is the most important
challenge right now even though of
course you know we should figure out and
this is by the way what you're working
you guys
in context of fairness and that's
something that also i do in context of
reliability saying okay maybe even like
what robust means it may be hard to
define but however i provide you with
tools that if you think you know what it
is you know i can help you to make your
model like satisfy you know what you are
looking for so that's kind of but but we
need to recognize that this is kind of
this is a challenge but it's kind of a
secondary to me in terms of like what
the really important question is
so there's a very interesting audience
question that i would like to uh now
pull up and articulate
so it's from fairdos who is one of our
usual gang
attendees so he's asking can you comment
on the implications of aiml as applied
in the area of security intelligence
facial recognition surveillance and
others
alexander you want to go first
yes sorry i just because i needed to
tell someone that you know because we
are going a bit over time yeah so
sorry so the question was about
like could you repeat i'm sorry yeah the
it's ai
ml applied in the area of security and
intelligence right the sort of the
facial recognition surveillance and so
on
yes so you know like i think this is
kind of scary and to be honest when i
work on on my staff there is you know
some moments in the night where you are
thinking you know kind of
what are we enabling so even though of
course the users we are using our tools
for i would say are all i feel pretty
confident and moral about them you know
there are clearly like all the ways in
which these things can be misused
so you know in particular like yes like
must like so going back to our
discussion earlier it's like i think
what we don't really appreciate is the
ability of like the vastness of data
that essentially like whose analysis
machine learning can automatically like
i don't think we even understand mass
surveillance in particular or facebook
like we don't even think about you know
kind of what is the level of like what
is enabled by you know
by doing that so to be honest i don't
know that either like so if you want to
see you know of course there's facial
recognition there is like you know if we
look at china and you know other
countries like there are some you know
there are some challenges there but you
know the problem you know like the
probably think about social media for
instance yes like kind of you know if
you think about the level of
surveillance that's happening there
where you know not only what you like or
not like or what you write is taken care
of it's just they look at your cursor
like what do you even scroll over where
your cursor is how long does it change
all of this is ingested and it's like
it's just so easy to like pull all this
data show up into the systems and
honestly like we don't understand what
you are extracting or not but kind of
you know the system just work on that so
so to me like you know again all the
security aspects are important this is
kind of another kind of words like how
do we you know if we want to not only
it's about okay can someone compromise
you know a compromise the system but the
question is like people think about also
in terms of offensive capabilities can i
automate my you know my tools using ml
making the data driven essentially
remove the slow human from the loop like
this is scary and there are some like
you know a kind of quite uh you know
quite scary scenarios that can emerge
from this kind of dynamics and again you
know just like a preview of this was the
stock market you know and like when you
have like automated trading and there
was a flash crashes like i think that's
just like an example where again
everyone during that game wanted to get
the right thing they just wanted to get
efficiency they wanted to kind of get
this you know extra you know extra tick
uh
and essentially like you know and
something was you know this is such a
level of you know of uh like such a
scale of data and interactions that we
don't see but again
let's not even talk about that think
about social media and about what
emerges from again simple and i would
even say simplistic
objectives
and then just shoving in all this data
into it just because it's just so easy
so so this is kind of this worries me a
lot i think that's why we should talk
about privacy more not only because
again privacy is this to me a
fundamental right but also about like
you know this might be a way to curb a
little bit the unintended consequences
of you know of use of our data for
optimizing everything
nishite did you want to weigh in
or i think alexander covered uh
pretty much all that i would have said
uh yeah i think this technology is not
ready and i think i'll just add one
thing to it you know even though you
might develop a piece of algorithm
with very in a very controlled
environment
you know it's so just i mean to give an
analogy to cars or any other things that
people have more familiarity with so you
know cars car production was
systematized they were like you know
protocols that you have to follow and
you know and so on so you can you can
i mean it's it doesn't work like that
with algorithms you can design an
algorithms in a very safe environment in
a very with lots of guarantees but now
somebody takes that algorithm right what
i mean tinkering a car is not so easy
okay so i mean common people cannot here
you can open the python code and just
start changing the rates somewhere right
or
just feed it on some train it on a few
more examples right i mean so in the end
the model that you train you know it can
be used as a starting point for
something else there are some very
complex things like data poisoning and
this and that it just uh it's just a
jungle out there so i'm not sure uh you
know how
we when we
even if we develop a piece of algorithm
in a very precise and
nice and
you know context unless you know when we
give it to somebody to use we basically
lock it out somehow so they can't change
any aspect of it
uh it seems like uh yeah it seems like
yeah i think that's what i would say the
technology is not ready uh for any of
these tasks
and uh
you know the
the biases uh are already in there right
so the biases with respect to facial
recognition
and so on are already in there so we
need to
rethink how we want to design this
technology uh completely
both from a reliability point of view
and from a furnace point of view so uh
let's close with one final question from
our audience which is related to the
topics you both
touched upon right now and this is also
from jenny who's one of our regulars in
how how far does the sample size of data
also play a role in the development of
fair algorithms some questions can only
be based on the law of small numbers
instead of in the limit of large numbers
how to take sparse correlated samples
into account
so this is uh yeah this is a
this is a great question um
i mean we have some
works
which try to take into account
um correlations whether they are
stochastic or adversarial
and then work out the sample complexity
bounds
for
learning
classifiers so classifier classification
and one of the basic machine learning
tasks
uh i mean there's no question and
there's no answer for this life in
general so it can only be with respect
to a particular problem and if the
problem is classification
uh yes we we i mean um
uh we are working towards it and there
are certain precise mathematical
solutions
to these problems i'm not sure that i
can explain more without going into
mathematical details
yes so so i just want to say that like
you know this is just like and the
platform was invented by the question
but like we need to be careful with the
mantra of more data we'll solve problems
because again more data might have just
reinforced the same bias so we might
thinking we are making progress where we
aren't so there's a lot of question
about kind of exactly like you know data
with
is independent or in some ways provides
different perspective like it actually
would be fine if this perspective are
biased as long as they are biased in
different ways and actually we even have
a work that kind of tries to exactly use
that perspective of kind of you know i
have you know or maybe it is biased in
some way but these are different biases
and you can play them against each other
to realize like what is the less biased
perspective so
but yes this is the bit of a problem in
the community was that people just said
oh i train it on such a big you know on
such a big data data set so it has to be
good because accuracy goes up in
particular like you know gpt free like
you know is trained on like a lot of
text and you know again
is very impressive
but like i would not bet
actually i would bet that there are a
lot of biases in in in it that we
probably wouldn't like to have so so
data is definitely like needed
but it's definitely not sufficient to
you know to solve this problem
great um i i think um much as i would
have uh loved us to keep uh talking uh
because it's absolutely fascinating and
you know learnt a lot and our audience
is really thrilled to have this
opportunity
i think we need to call it to a close uh
i would like to thank both of you
alexander and nishith for
participating um in this exciting sort
of series trying to understand the role
of data computation machine learning
in what we can infer about the world and
how we infer about the world
so thank you everyone uh for attending
and uh look forward to seeing you at the
next talk in this series by which will
be led by kyle cranmer who is a
physicist at nyu who works on machine
learning applied to particle physics
experimental data
and
i also want to take this opportunity to
say happy thanksgiving a break to all of
you
who hopefully can catch up a few restful
days with your families
thank you everyone and good evening bye